i mean i've had the the death source
that they sell here which is technically
ghost pepper
sauce but like it's water yeah but
that's the thing right it's like if
we're talking like just raw peppers like
i've only done habanero
yeah i mean i think the spiciest thing
like singular thing i've ever had
uh was back in university where it was
like it wasn't even like a ghost pepper
it was a ghost pepper
oh yeah the actually the extract which
is like even more like it was
it wasn't like i mean this concentrated
ghostly yeah yeah exactly it was just
like the pure extract and
i never like at this point you know i'd
obviously like still grown up on spicy
food but i've nev i've never had like a
ghost pepper
or like an actual one of the famous hot
peppers that people
do youtube challenges over uh about so
um i remember this
we were drinking and my mate he had this
ghost pepper extract that he was like
daring people were just carrying it
around was he yeah yeah because he's
that [ __ ] yeah
he he he was like that guy he he was the
guy
you know you know the guy who would show
people the two girls one cup 100 videos
we all have that one friend like like
the pain olympics
he was that friend so of course he had
this ghost
he was recently yeah which i found
really funny what was that you only
found out what goats he was like
god didn't know what it was and if you
don't know what it is please don't don't
look it up
it is someone's cheeks being spread
that's all you need to know yeah so so
so we had so we had this um so you had
this ghost pepper extract
and of course we were drinking as you
were at university
and uh we had gotten to the point where
we we we were like tipsy enough to start
you know contemplating doing stupid [ __ ]
and of course you know
you know you know you know he's gonna
commit credit card forward yeah you know
he's an experienced friend where he
brings it out at exactly the right time
of the night where everyone's
everyone's intoxicated enough to like
think that it's a good idea
what a horrible friend yeah she's
waiting till everyone is just
semi-stupid start feeding them poison
exactly so he brings out this extract
and he's like yo
i don't i dare anyone to [ __ ] do this
right and i see people doing it
and they're taking like the tiniest the
tiniest little
like drop yeah right it's not even a
drop it's like less than a drop
right and i see people [ __ ] dying and
me um being like yo yo
giggity chad that i am these these weak
ass white guys don't know their [ __ ]
spice
well look look at all these guys right
and so so it gets smiter and i'm just
like
oh i'll show i'll show you how man does
it so so like there's
certain famous laughs never ever said
that out loud
it's not a god phrase no if there's one
thing i was confident
it's taking [ __ ] spice levels i don't
think you'd ever say and i quote let me
show you how a man
so like so like how the extract works is
like you have this like tiny little
spoon right yeah yeah yeah
that you can like put like one little
drip on so like i fill up the spoon and
i just [ __ ]
shove it in my mouth i i did not know
how spicy it was right
right and i never i never knew that
i could literally feel like i've been
shot in the face until i i
like it was just the biggest instant
regret moment of my life like normally
normally you see people taking like they
they take the carolina retail
repo they chew on it and there's like
this delay yeah right yeah
no there was there was not that was not
a single delay in my mind
yeah my my body went into like fight or
flight mode
immediately like i was fine i i took it
and then like five seconds later i swear
i was in the [ __ ] fetal position just
like ah
oh god it hurts so much i'm gonna try
this now this sounds fun
it's it's it's okay sorry what what do
you want
it's interesting i'd like to try i will
say i do not recommend it
as someone who can't handle my spice i
literally um
it was nice taken don't worry it was an
experience
that kid who saw like jackass i was like
i want to do that yeah
because what happened is i was i was out
of commission for the entire night
because it was so spicy that it just
induced my gag reflex
so i was i was like i was on the toilet
i was like in the bathroom for like a
good three hours just like
gagging on on the toilet couldn't throw
up it was just like my gag reflex just
like
my body trying to throw up this thing
that was like one one little drop so
like there was nothing to throw up it
was like a drop
right but it it had induced this gag
reflex and i was on the toilet for about
three hours
and uh my you know my my university
mates being the good mates that they
were
they're just just they just kind of went
clubbing and just left
you while you're on the toilet fantastic
well what a fantastic group of mates
well that's
i mean that's why i'm not friends with
them anymore
long story short i'm not in contact with
any of my uni mates anymore but uh
i'm not i'm not caught up with many
either yeah they didn't poison me
yeah exactly they were nice to me maybe
what if it was all a ruse game where
they all agreed to
take small amounts of this just so that
god would step up to the place
let me show you yeah they were all like
oh we want to go clubbing but we don't
want to take guns
how can we how do we knock him out let's
get him out of commission yeah i know a
way i know a way that gotten the fall
through
that's why that's i think that's what
they did maybe yeah the spice challenge
but yeah that's uh
like i i i think i've read that no one
has ever died from spice before
or like go into shock though yeah i
think so yeah
i don't know i didn't melan look it up
has anyone ever died from spice
yeah they can go okay so you can't die
from the chemical itself but you can die
from shock you can die from the pain
it induces yeah yeah yeah yeah you can
go in like cardiac arrest
yeah basically it's fun yeah basically
basically just don't just don't do
something
don't go into cardiac arrest
doctors haters just get better arteries
10 ways to stop heart attacks just don't
go in there just don't uh don't
don't take ghost pepper extract or any
kind of extract you know i wasn't going
to
yeah i think i'm still not going to yeah
i think that's that's
right i'm good
you can stop breathing okay just
manually pump those [ __ ]
it was just like that scene from [ __ ]
pulp fiction right i just
i just passed down they have to forget
the [ __ ] needle and inject it
straight into my heart
oh god my god